yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
the 14th film in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe Doctor Strange brings the
eponymous superheroes origin tale to the
big screen and at the same time sneaks
in a good number of Easter eggs so the
comic books and the wider MCU in this
video put together all the Easter eggs
and references like a spot in the movie
as always do let me know in the comments
below any other cool Easter eggs you
spotted too just before I get stuck in
I'm running a giveaway for this awesome
hardback book from DK called the
mysterious world of Doctor Strange it's
packed with over 170 pages of
illustrations and info and showcases
many of the weird and wonderful
characters monsters demons and demigods
that have appeared in Marvel's Doctor
Strange comics over the years four
charts win a copy all you have to do is
subscribe and leave a comment or reply
to a comment on this video and just a
quick warning that there will be
spoilers in this video so if you're not
ready for that click here to watch my
spoiler free review of the movie the art
of Steve Ditko's Doctor Strange comics
was a major influence and reference
point for the look of the dark dimension
in the multiverse that we see during
Steven strangers magical mystery tour
and during his confrontation with
Dormammu interestingly over a year was
spent on previz & concept off the new
dimensions that we see in the film and
the filmmakers themselves are said they
very much wanted to pay tribute to
Ditko's original weird and wonderful
artwork from the 60s to make sure their
movie was indeed strange a more recent
comic book influence was 2007 The Oath
with the movie reflecting the fun tone
of that miniseries but there are also
some specific Easter eggs to that
particular comic book story arc in the
movie Christine Palmer has to operate on
a badly injured strange just as night
nesters in the comic and in both the
movie and the comics as a humorous scene
where strange suddenly appears as an
astral projection of himself during the
procedure and the number 280 which we
see briefly on the back of strangers
broken watch is also an Easter Egg to
the comic dr. strange volume 2 issue 80
where strange materializes as his astral
form to doctors operating on his injured
body unlike in the comics Rachel McAdams
is character Christine Palmer doesn't
get the moniker of night nurse in the
movie in the comics the name night nurse
is more of a shared moniker taken on by
various characters who look after
injured superheroes in the movie
Christine Palmer is a doctor and not an
which is perhaps a nod to the joke in
the oath comic this another night nurse
character makes about why she has that
alias even though she's actually a
doctor still the film makes a subtle
allusion to the character of night nurse
as we see Christine Palmer become the
go-to doctor to treat super-powered
individuals like dr. strange and the
ancient one when they arrive at the
hospital and strange and Palmer's
previous romantic history in the film
tips its hat to the romance between dr.
strange and night nurse at the end of
the oath by the way if you enjoy
Marvel's Netflix TV shows you'll know
that there have been lots of allusions
to Rosario Dawson's character Claire
temple as being night nurse the
character of Nicodemus West is also
taken from the oaths series were like in
the movie he's also the doctor who
operated on strangers hands after his
accident and Marvel's graphic novel in
to Shambala gets a cheeky easter egg in
the form of the Wi-Fi password at c'mon
Tosh Doctor Strange is on-screen origin
story borrows significantly from the
comics with his depiction as an arrogant
surgeon who turns down patience his car
accident and going penniless trying to
find a cure for his hands until he
discovers come on Tosh and the ancient
one the address of the New York sanctum
sanctorum 177 eight Bleecker Street is a
nod to the same address in the comics
which was actually also the address of
an apartment that Marvel comic book
writers worry Thomas and Gary Friedrich
once shirt given that by the end of the
movie 177 a Bleecker Street becomes a
new residents of dr. strange it's
interesting that it has a similar ring
to Sherlock's 221 B Baker Street
Benedict Cumberbatch of course play
Sherlock in the BBC TV series and I
found it intriguing that also some of
the music that plays during the film and
over the credits had a Sherlock themed
music meets Pink Floyd vibe to it and
during the scene where strange is
driving along the winding road you can
clearly hear Pink Floyd's track
interstellar overdrive' it's hardly
surprising that their psychedelic rock
features in the movie soundtrack after
all back in 1968 the band used artwork
from the comic strange tales on the
cover of their second album a Saucerful
of Secrets and much more recently
Benedict Cumberbatch actually performed
the song comfortably numb' on stage in
London with former Pink Floyd guitarist
and vocalist David Gilmour the cloak of
levitation from the comics gets a bit of
an update from the iconic comic book
design though it keeps the main red
colour losing the gold colors except for
the clasps around the top and the cloaks
animated character
ADEs of the magic carpet from Disney's
animated movie Aladdin about it the seal
of Ashanti appears in the movie in the
skylight that each of the sanctum
sanctorum Zahn the doors and on the
luminous glow but Kumar Taj as well as
on the eye of agamotto in the comics to
the Shanti are a union of three mystical
god-like beings who protect the earth
one of the vishanti is agamotto who gets
name checked in the film as a father of
the mystic arts and the first sorcerer
supreme the amulets the eye of agamotto
is named after him an in the comics as
various powers while in the MCU it's
used by dr. strange to manipulate time
and at the end of the film wall reveals
that the eye is actually one of the six
Infinity stones specifically the time
stone is curious too that the movie
seems to be setting the MCU up for
Thanos to come and take the Infinity
stone by just leaving it in a room that
was already breached by Kai simius and
his Ellis earlier in this film the book
from which kycilia strips the pages he
needs to summon Dormammu is a book of
Kali Ostrow a reference to the mystical
book in the comics which Mordo used to
travel back in time the staff of the
Living Tribunal which Mordo reels while
training with strange is possibly a
reference to the staff of polar power
from the comics which has the ability to
absorb evil magical energy but it's also
an easter egg to the Living Tribunal a
cosmic being that protects the
multiverse in the comics this is the
first time that the name has been
mentioned in the MCU and it might have
implications for infinity war as in the
comics the Living Tribunal has power
that exceeds the Infinity Gauntlet
Mario's vaulting boots of Valtor are not
to the comic book entity belt or Hugh
Grant's power to anyone who can invoke
him and thanks to those boots in the
movie Mordo seems to be able to leap a
great distance Wong's weapon that he
grabs to defend the Hong Kong sanctum is
the wand of watoomb we don't really see
what it can do in the movie but in the
comics it can defend against mystical
attacks as well as open portals to other
dimensions the luminous orange colored
magic that dr. strange uses is derived
from an energy force called eldritch
light it can be harnessed to slash and
shield type weapons or as an eldritch
whip which we often see him use and the
luminous orange ropes that kycilia see
zealots used to bind the librarian at
kamata's in midair look like the emcee
used version of the comics crimson bow
of site auric a spell that contains a
prisoner within its bands when strange
tries to run in grab an axe in the
sanctum during his battle with chi
Silius is likely a nod to the axe of
anger roomis a weapon that dr. strange
acquired in the 2015 relaunch of a new
Doctor Strange comic book series and the
artifact in the sanctum which kycilia
smock strange for not knowing what it
does is the brazier of bong Goliath in
the comics the brassiere allows
interdimensional travel between realms
Master Hermia who strange confuses for
the ancient one upon his arrival at
Kumar Taj is an updated version of
Hermia from the comics who is an
assistant to the ancient one the rider
MCU also gets a couple of references
with Wang name-dropping The Avengers as
defending the world against physical
threats whereas the Masters safeguard
the world against mystical threats and
we also see the Avengers tower in some
of the shots of the New York skyline
there's a possible reference to Iron Man
2 during the phone conversation Strange
has while driving just before his crash
Billy who is telling strange about
possible new patience mentions a 35 year
old Marine Colonel that crushed his
lower spine and some kind of
experimental armor this could be a
reference to the hammer tech test pilots
injured when the Iron Man ripoff suit he
was wearing twisted a hundred and eighty
degrees on his upper half while his legs
were stuck where they were Tony Stark
played the video of the injury during
the Senate Armed Forces Committee
hearing in Iron Man 2 Marvel legend Stan
Lee cameos in the scene were Doctor
Strange and Mordo tipped sideways onto a
bus bike high Silius as he folds the
streets to stop them escaping through a
gateway Lee is riding on the bus and
reading the doors of perception by
Aldous Huxley laughing at the craziness
of it all the doors of perception is a
book about what Aldous Huxley
experienced after taking the drug
mescaline in 1953 and the reference is a
tongue-in-cheek nod to the psychedelic
aesthetic of the movie and the original
Ditko comics a surprising cameo you may
not have noticed is that Benedict
Cumberbatch perform the motion capture
for Dormammu and casting Cumberbatch in
the role is kind of apt when you
consider that director scott derrickson
has said that Dormammu is a kind of
ultra inflated version of strange and
ego run amok by the way the design of
Dormammu in the movie with a kind of
folded face is a visual shout-out to the
way that Dormammu was originally drawn
by dick Kerr with stripes in the
characters head there's a small cameo
for the character of Daniel Drum who's
the master of the new
Sanctum before kycilia arrives and kills
him Daniel drum who's also dead in the
comics as a brother called Jericho aka
brother voodoo who takes on the mantle
of sorcerer supreme from dr. strange in
the New Avengers comics as a blink in
you'll miss it cameo vitina Minoru
played by Linda Louise to Anne she
appears briefly with the ancient one and
Daniel drum and later momentarily in the
Hong Kong sanctum
Tina manaro is the mother of Nico Minoru
a lead character in Marvel's The
Runaways comics which are being adapted
as a hulu TV series then Collins aka the
Stig from Top Gear is actually the stunt
driver for dr. strangers car crash the
mid-credits scene features a cameo from
Chris Hemsworth as Thor and teases a
Doctor Strange appearance in the
upcoming Thor Ragnarok in the scene
Doctor Strange is wearing a pair of
yellow gloves a hat tip to the gold and
colored gloves that dick go drew for
Doctor Strange you can also click here
for more detailed analysis of that scene
or you can check the link later in the
video description below
more dough's turn to the dark side in
the post-credits scene links up the
character to his classic villain role of
Baron Mordo in the comics and he's
dressed in muted green colors in the
film a hat tip to his comic-book
counterparts classic green costume
there's also more references to more doz
villainous backgrounds and earlier
points in the movie for example when
Waldo says state should 1 I've wanted
the power to defeat my enemies and when
the ancient one comments a strange that
maldo soul was forged by the fires vis
youth you can click here for more
details on the post-credits scene and
what it means for a Doctor Strange
sequel and I'll also put a link in the
video description below there's a fair
bit of product placement in Doctor
Strange but there's a Marvel related one
for synchrony bank whose name appears on
the building that gets split and warped
into during one of the mind-bending
action scenes synchrony bank is Marvel's
official partner and issuer of the
Marvel Master Card and finally over the
movies end credits we hear the theme
called the master of the mystic end
credits which is a nod to the second
series of Doctor Strange comics which
was subtitled master of the mystic arts
now I'd love to hear about any other
Easter eggs and references that I missed
and do let me know what you thought of
the movie too don't forget to subscribe
and leave a comment for a chance to win
this awesome hardback book the
mysterious world of Doctor Strange and
do ten on your note
or flicks in the city to make sure you
stay up to date with all my videos if
you enjoyed this I appreciate you liking
and sharing it and why not take a look
at more videos on my Doctor Strange and
easter eggs playlist you can click any
of the links below to check those out
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee-ki-yay movie lovers